[MUSIC PLAYING]
IKAI LAN: Hi.
Welcome to another edition of
YouTube Developers Live.
My name is Ikai Lan.
I'm based in New York City,
and I work on YouTube
Developer Relations team.
Jeff Posnick is also here, but
he's sitting behind the camera
operating things.
So say hi to Jeff.
He'll be listening.
Today we're going to be
talking about InVideo
Programming and the InVideo
Programming API.
So what's going to happen is
that we're going to talk about
what InVideo Programming is.
And what it is, it's a way to
promote your channel and
videos you want to highlight to
get people to subscribe and
watch more in your channel.
And what we're going to do is
we're going to show you how to
use API in Python and Java as
well as how to use the API
with the Analytics API.
So it's not going to be as long
as our regular shows, but
I promise you, guys, it's going
to be a great show.
So why don't we go ahead
and get started.
I'm going to show you guys
what's on my screen.
I will apologize.
I'm not going to be completely
zoomed in because it turns out
it's kind of a pain to zoom
back and forth on certain
applications, and this is
actually my work computer.
So let's go ahead and
show you guys what
InVideo Programming is.
I'm going to zoom in
on my browser here.
Here's a channel.
And you'll see Dino Dinosaur.
That's a test name that I used
for my test account.
And I've got a bunch
of uploads here.
And they're kind of
silly uploads.
They're just me kind of goofing
around, or it's me
playing video games.
But let's pretend that I do have
a real YouTube channel,
and I want people to watch
my channel and
keep watching my channel.
I want people to subscribe
to my channel.
So I've got a lot of different
options for promoting them,
and the option we'll be talking
about today is InVideo
Programming.
So the problem that InVideo
Programming solves is when
someone comes across
your video, you
want them to subscribe.
And there are lots of different
ways to do this.
So one way to do it is
InVideo Programming.
Other ways include things such
as advertising your channel,
showing a playlist, promoting
off youtube.com.
And that's all good.
But really, you want people not
just to watch one video.
You want them to become repeat
viewers of your channels and
your content.
So you'll see that right here,
I just went to the InVideo
Programming tab in my admin.
And I got here by going to the
top-right corner of YouTube,
clicking on Video Manager, going
to Channel Settings, and
InVideo Programming.
And InVideo Programming is
a channel-wide setting.
And that's important to
remember, because later on
when we're working with the API,
we'll be looking at the
Channels API.
So let's take a look at
InVideo Programming.
There are two options
right now.
One is to feature
your channel--
or a channel, really.
And this lets you
set a channel.
This lets you set your logo or
your branding in a certain
part of the video or for all
the videos on a channel.
So here I've just got a silly
icon of a Go Gopher and then a
YouTube Play icon.
And I'm picking that I want to
show this in the top right for
the entire video.
So anytime someone comes to
watch my video, they will see
this logo, and they will be
able to click through and
learn more about my channel.
So this is pretty cool for
branding your videos without
having to explicitly brand them
inside the video, and it
also makes them interactive
immediately.
So the next feature is
the Featured Video.
And the featured video allows
you to show a preview of a
different video for a
certain duration.
In this case, I'm showing some
silly video in the bottom
left-hand corner.
I'm showing at the end of the
video, and I'm showing it for
10 seconds.
So what you want to put here
is a video that highlights
kind of the best that you have
to offer or something recent,
something that'll make the video
viewer continue watching
your content and become engaged
with your channel and
subscribe to your channel.
So let's take a look at what
this looks like in a video.
All right.
Now, here's a video
I've uploaded.
It's really silly.
It was a day when I wore
a suit to work.
And as you know, we always wear
suits to work at Google.
And yes, this was a day
when I shot a show.
So you'll see a show when
I'm wearing a suit, and
this was that day.
I was creating a bunch
of test videos.
So as I'm playing this video,
you'll see two things.
First off, we'll see
three things.
You'll see me goofing off.
And if you're watching this
show, you know that I'm not--
that's something I rarely
do is goof off.
And there are two things.
One is that I have a logo.
And this is my channel
branding.
So when I click here, it takes
me to my channel so users can
learn more about my channel.
My channel's not very
interesting.
It's a test channel.
But your channel's going to look
a lot better than this.
Now, the second option here is
that I'm highlighting a video.
And because this video is only
4 seconds long, a 10-second
end-of-video duration means that
this InVideo Programming
icon shows up for the
entire video.
Now, you're not always going
to want to do this because
it's going to be distracting,
but this is a
really short video.
So it doesn't hurt
us too much.
So right here is a demo video.
And this is a video of a demo
that we like to do where of my
the teammates, Jarek, he created
a game where you can
throw ping pong balls at a
gasoline can, record and
upload to YouTube.
Not super interesting, but we
have found that if you're a
game developer, integrating with
YouTube often has really
asymmetric benefits for you
relative to the amount of work
you put into it.
So I'm going to click
through that.
And theoretically, you want
to show off the--
what are these related videos?
You want to show off the content
that will make people
want to keep watching
your channel.
So what we might do, for
instance, on the Google
Developers channel, would be to
highlight the I/O keynote,
or highlight InVideo Programming
because Jeff has
accessed that account.
So there are a bunch of things
we can do, but what you want
to show here is the content
that will likely make you
click through and
keep watching.
And there are ways to do this
right now with the current
annotation setting, but InVideo
program is the way
we're going to be doing
this going forward.
And we're really excited to be
thinking about new features
and ways that we can be
enhancing this functionality.
OK, so here's my video of us.
This is a game.
This is a real game.
Throwing tennis balls
at gasoline cans.
And that's the video.
And that's going to make me, a
regular YouTube watcher, want
to subscribe to this video, or
like it, or do whatever.
OK, so that's great.
But we're here to talk
about the API.
So now that you know what
the feature is, we
can get down to business.
Now I mentioned that InVideo
program is a
channel-wide setting.
And that's why when you're at
the YouTube API reference,
you'll see developers.googl
e.com/youtube/v3.
You want to go to the Channels
documentation.
So the Channels documentation,
right now
there are two methods--
List and Update.
List is a read operation,
whereas
update is a write operation.
And we're operating on
the Channel resource.
So if you don't really follow
what we're talking about here,
one show that I highly recommend
is a show we did a
few weeks ago about turning the
API reference into code.
And you can find this show at
youtube.com/youtubedev and
just look at our playlist of
recent GDL shows where we
explain how to make sense of the
API reference and how to
quickly turn this into usable
code that you can put into
your applications.
OK, so let's scroll down.
And we're working with a channel
resource, but we're
working with one part of
a channel resource.
And scrolling all the way down,
we're working with the
invideoPromotion part of
the channel resource.
And this shows some of the
different fields that a
channel will return if it has
invideoPromotion set up.
And more documentation on
invideoPromotion will be on
the same page, on the Channels
documentation page.
When you scroll all the way
down, you'll see hey, there's
InVideoPromotion and there
is the promotion,
timing, offset, type.
And I'll talk about
these right now.
So there aren't a lot of
settings for this today.
But that's good because it
means the API is simple.
Inside of your promotion,
you set a few things.
You set a timing.
And a timing consists of a type,
which is when you want
this promotion to show up.
And this is only for the
featured video, by the way.
I should mention
that right now.
Do you want it to show up at
the end of video, or do you
want it to show up at
some other offset?
And how many milliseconds?
And this is important.
This is not in seconds.
This is milliseconds.
I opened a bug with the
engineering team that works on
this because I put in 15, and
I was wondering why my
promotion never appeared.
And it's because I configured
it for 15
milliseconds, not 15 seconds.
So 15 seconds would be 15000.
The position, and the position,
there are four corners--
top left, top right, bottom
left, and bottom right.
And you'll see that this is a
string value that allows you
to pick these.
Now, the next thing here is
the type and the video ID.
And the type right now
is only video.
And the video is just
a video ID of the
video you want to promote.
So you'll see that this
items is an array.
Really, this only
takes one value.
You can try putting in multiple
values, but the API
will throw an error.
So even though it's an array,
only include one
object of this type.
So let's go ahead to the
Try It Now button.
And if you watch, again, our
show about how to turn the API
reference into code, I
go into more detail
about how to use this.
But what you want to do is when
you're creating a request
payload, the property that
you want to add is
invideoProgramming.
And you'll see that--
oops, excuse me.
I'm using zoom on my computer.
It lets you set position and
the position properties.
And this is just being
crazy right now.
The corner position-- and this
is a string, of course-- top
left, top right, bottom
left, bottom right.
That has to match the
[? store error. ?]
You could set the items.
And inside the items, this
is when you will add a
type and a video ID.
So it's a very simple API.
And if you need to take a look
at what this payload might
look like, again, scroll up
and look at the Channel
resource to see what the
payload will look like.
So the resource
representation, we scroll down.
We see that there's a timing
and a position and items.
All right.
Now let's start translating
this into code.
What I'm going to do is I'm
going to show you guys the
Java code of how to
run a Java sample.
We've created this.
It's not currently on the site,
but we will push this to
YouTube API sample soon.
And that'll be available at--
you could search for it at
YouTube API samples.
And that will be the first link
in your favorite search
engine right here.
So we haven't pushed it yet,
but we will push it.
And once we do, this will make a
lot of sense when you can go
through the code.
OK, so after we go through the
Java sample, I'm going to go
through the Python sample, and
we're going to go through a
Python sample that shows you
how to do some stuff with
Google Analytics--
or not Google,
excuse me, YouTube Analytics.
All right.
So this is my Java ID.
I use IntelliJ.
I use a dark theme because I
think the light theme kind of
hurts my eyes.
So the first thing I'm going to
mention is that all of our
samples use Maven.
And there's one thing you have
to remember if you're using
our samples or if you're
using Maven.
It's that you have to upload
your YouTube client versions.
So you'll see that I'm
using 1.15 RC.
RC stands for Release
Candidate.
And when I scroll down, if
you're not using variables in
Maven, you're just going
to pass it in.
That will go under the
com.google.apis right here--
dependency.
And you'll want to put that the
client version you want
for the YouTube artifact
is 1.15, the release
candidate for that.
And the reason for that is that
our APIs that you find in
the API reference, there's
what's called a Discovery doc,
and the clients are all
auto-generated from the
Discovery doc.
So the statically
typed clients.
Like Java and C#, we have to go
ahead and regenerate a new
client version whenever we add
a new field in a new API.
And this is a little bit
cumbersome, but it's kind of
nice, because then you get
all the benefits of using
statically typed languages such
as code completion and
just type checking.
And I found that this is
actually really helpful.
Maybe I'll do a show sometime
comparing static and dynamic
languages, throw some fuel
on that flame more.
So again, you have to upload
this to the latest version for
this to work.
And what you'll see is
you'll see a couple
of deprecation warnings.
So I'll be updating the samples
over the next few days
so that you won't see those
deprecation warnings anymore.
We've changed just a few
things about how
some classes work.
We won't talk about
that today.
OK, so after you do that, and
you do an MVN update, so I'm
right here.
This is the command line.
And MVN update, this is just
saying Maven, update my
dependencies.
I guess I've done that wrong.
Anyway, MVN compile will
update everything.
So you'll see that I've
compiled everything.
I sometimes forget what the
commands are because I switch
tools so much.
Little plug for myself, I've
been working with Gradle a lot
recently because I've been
working on Android.
And that's a really
cool build tool.
You can also use Maven artifacts
and download from
remote repositories.
And the whole thing is just
idiomatic Groovy.
So the Groovy Programming
language lets you do some
pretty cool things, and I've
been a long-time advocate of
build systems that
are actually DSLs
of Programming languages.
This gives you a lot of
power and flexibility.
But again, personal opinion.
End soap box.
So now, let's go
back to our ID.
We're going through
the Java code.
And this is the Java
sample code for
adding a featured video.
And I've got a couple
dependencies I need to remove.
I was messing around with
this yesterday.
OK.
So you'll see that the first
thing we do is-- this looks
like a narrow sample, where
we've got to read a client's
secrets, and this file contains
our client ID and
client secret.
We authorize, and we put the
user through a three-legged
OAuth flow, which is to say
we open a browser window.
A user says, OK, I want to
authorize this application.
And then we go ahead and
we make the API call.
And the API call looks
like this.
The sample is first going to
pull up a list of all your
channels and get the
very first channel.
So you'll see that I'm just
getting the first channel.
This is returned in
the items array.
Now, once we have the channel
ID, we're going to get the
playlist ID for uploads.
This sample is going to take
my most recent upload and
feature that video.
So this is kind of cool if you
always want to be driving
people to the newest video
that you've uploaded.
So you can do some cool stuff
where you can make this
totally automated using
push notifications.
So if you want to learn a
little bit about push
notifications, check out Jeff
Posnick and Yaniv's push
notification talk at Google I/O.
You can also find that at
youtube.com/googledevelopers.
So you can make it so on some
kind of notification, say, a
new video is added to
a playlist, you
feature that video.
So you'll see that this is kind
of cool, and this is what
Java gets us, which is that
we have a channel.
We're going to say
get content.
Oh, jeez.
Excuse me, the zoom is
kind of crazy here.
I'm going to say get
content details.
We go into-- yikes.
We're just not going
to do that anymore.
Get Related Playlists,
and we're
going to say Get Uploads.
And this gives us a string
representing the playlist ID
for uploads.
This is one of the ways you
fetch uploads nowadays.
So now we have the string, which
gives us a playlist ID.
So now, what we're going to do
is we are going to fetch the
videos from a playlist.
And we do this by just making a
youtube.playlistitems API call.
We go through the videos, and if
the result is not empty, we
get a video ID.
And this is just very standard,
get the snippet, get
the resource ID, get
the video ID.
And this is a string
that we're going
to use in our sample.
So now we're going to get to
the part that describes
InVideo Programming.
So what we're going to do is
this is as with any update or
write operation using a Java
client, it's a little bit more
verbose, and that's because we
can't just pass an arbitrary
dictionary to the API like
we can in Python or Ruby.
What we need to do is we need
to create typed objects that
represent the data we
want to update.
So this includes a position,
which we've set
at the bottom left.
We set the type to corner.
Right now there's only corner,
but this gives us some ability
to expand on this API
in the future.
It makes it scalable,
so to speak.
The timing, we set the timing.
And this takes a big integer,
we're going to have to cast
our long into a big integer.
And we're going to set the
type to offsetFromEnd.
There are only two
options here.
You can find them in
the API reference.
We're going to set the
promoted item video.
Right now that's the
only option.
And we're going to set
the featured video.
We're going to set the video ID
to the video that we pulled
back, which was the latest video
that we've uploaded.
And then finally, we're going
to create the actual
InVideoPromotion object.
Whew!
That was a lot of work
to get here.
So once you create the promotion
object, we set the
position, which is the
position we created--
bottom left, top left,
whichever.
We set the timing.
We set the items, which even
though there's only one item
today, you have to
pass a list.
So I'm using a helper class
called Lists, which creates a
new array list, which
is one item.
And this takes any number of
items and creates a static--
not static, but it creates
an array list.
So this makes it easier than
saying list equals new array
list, arraylist.add, and then
put the array list.
It just saves us a few
lines of code.
All right.
So now that we've created the
InVideoPromotion object, we
create a new channel object.
And we set the ID to channel
ID we want to update.
We could have also used the
channel ID that we fetched
back from earlier
in the sample.
I think that's probably a better
idea, and I probably am
going to fix the sample so it
does that because this is just
getting a little bit more
verbose than it has to be.
OK.
We're going to set the
InVideoPromotion to the
InVideoPromotion object
we created.
And then at that point,
it's easy.
We say youtube.channels update,
and we want to update
this part, InVideoPromotion,
and we pass the channel.
We execute it.
So once that's done, this will
tell us that hey, we've gone
ahead and we've uploaded the--
we've set the new
InVideoPromotion.
So I'm going to go ahead
and run the sample for
you guys right now.
Live demos, be good to me.
We're going to run this using
Maven again, Maven Exec Java.
Let's see how this goes.
Oh, I know what's going on.
It's doing--
zoom is using keyboard focus
to decide what to zoom on.
OK, so now you'll see
that this has
opened a browser window.
And this is OAuth saying hey,
this application wants to run
as you, and it wants your
permission to do so.
So I'm going to click Accept.
It gets a verification code.
Oh, invalid client.
It means I set this client
up incorrectly.
But that's not a huge
deal because my
Python sample will work.
And the reason I've probably
set this up incorrectly is
because I've got some
weird stuff going on
with my client secrets.
So I'm not going to debug that
right now, but just to show
you that it will work--
demo gods!
OK, so now let's show you the
Python sample and what this
looks like there, opening up my
favorite editor for Python,
Sublime Text.
We're not going to zoom in since
it's really easy to make
the text bigger in
this application.
And this is a very
simple sample.
It looks really similar to the
other Python samples we have
for the YouTube API.
First off, we define a scope.
We create a YouTube client,
and we call the code.
And for the body, because this
is Python, we could just pass
a set of nested dictionaries,
and it'll take
this, and it'll work.
And in this particular sample,
we are taking keyword
arguments for channel ID
and a video ID to sets.
So you'll see that these are
the valid offset types and
valid positions.
There aren't a lot of choices,
and this will default some
positions for us.
And you could see that the
default that this is going to
do for us is going to be bottom
left and for 10 seconds.
But a user will be able to enter
command line arguments
and set this to something
different.
OK, so that's what the
sample is right now.
It's very straightforward.
And again, you'll see that
this payload looks very
similar to what you would see
in the API reference.
That is not an accident.
That is almost entirely
intentional.
So you can copy, paste them with
a few edits, make the API
reference portable
into your code.
And one thing that I'll mention
is that because the
libraries for Python are
auto-generated on the fly,
again from this Discovery
document, which it fetches
every time you run the
application, you don't need to
update the client at all.
If you have a working Google API
client, you've already got
everything you need to use the
newest version of the API.
So it's very, very cool.
But the trade-offs are that you
don't get type safety, and
the other issue is that if you
are going to be doing this a
lot, you usually want to do
caching of the Discovery doc.
So that's out of the scope of
this particular show, but you
don't want to be in a situation
where every single
time you are instantiating a
client, you are making a call,
especially if you're
instantiating an
API client a lot.
And the place where you don't
want to do this is say you are
building an API for an iOS
or Android application.
And what happens is you are
making an OAuth call,
an OAuth API call.
OAuth authorized the API call
from your server every single
time this application
checks in.
Now, you're going to be hitting
this Discovery doc
quite a bit, and there will be
some kind of caching going on,
but you're going to want to make
sure that you're caching
the Discovery doc yourself so
that you are not constantly
hitting the server and saying
what's the newest version of
the API, what's the newest
version of API.
Because the API will change,
but it's not
going to be that often.
All right.
So back on track.
This InVideoPromotion object,
we set a position,
and we set the items.
Looks very similar
to Java, but with
a little less ceremony.
So I'm going to go ahead and
run this code right now.
And you'll see that over here,
I have InVideo saved.
I'm calling Python,
InVideo sample.
I'm passing a channel ID.
This is my channel ID
and a video ID.
And I got these values from
looking at my channel.
And this is my Dino
Dinosaur channel.
You'll see it in the URL.
That's my channel ID, and I'm
just copying and pasting it
into the command line.
And as for the video,
I got that video,
again, from the URL.
OK, so let's go ahead
and run the sample.
You'll see something interesting
any time you see
me running Python, and that is
that I have a little prefix in
my command line.
I'm using something called
virtualenv, which is a Python
tool that lets you build out
separate Python environments.
And this is really important
because you don't always want
to be what we call polluting
your global Python space.
So virtualenv's a great tool.
If you're writing any kind of
Python, I highly recommend it.
All right.
I'm going to go ahead
and run this sample.
And you'll see that I've
added a featured
video to the channel.
So looking at the channel now,
if we refresh this page,
you'll see that we are using
the newest video, and we've
updated this to 10 seconds.
So I'm going to set it to 5 so
you could see this at work.
I'm going to hit Save.
Whoops, valid time values, 05.
I'm going to go ahead and update
it through the API.
And you'll see that the
API has changed
it back to 10 seconds.
All right.
So one last thing before I let
you guys go, and that is how
to use InVideo Programming
with Analytics.
So you can already get Analytics
via the Web Admin.
And you go that by clicking on
Analytics, scroll down, and
annotation says beta because
we're still working on this.
And aw, no one watches
watch my channel and
no one clicks through.
But what you should see is that
in the annotation type,
it'll say InVideo Programming
logo and featured video and
the clickthrough rate.
So I'm going to go ahead and run
a different sample for you
guys after I go through
this code.
And this sample is what
I call the InVideo
with Analytics sample.
And what this does is this gets
data about your InVideo
Programming, about
your channel.
Then it goes ahead and it prints
out, sorted by country,
what has the highest
click through rate.
So I have this tied to the
Google Developers channel
because I want to
provide slightly
more interesting data.
If I just provide it with my
channel, it would just be a
bunch of zeroes all
the way down.
So you'll see that because this
is combining the data API
and the Analytics API.
In the API console, you have to
enable both the Analytics
and the Data API.
Once you do, you'll
see that I've
defined two service names--
YouTube and YouTube
Analytics--
two versions.
And the scopes I'm using,
if I scroll up,
I'm using two scopes.
I'm using the YouTube read-only
scope as well as the
Analytics read-only scope.
I need two scopes because
I'm working with more
than one API here.
Now, I'm going to go ahead,
and in the main part, main
function, define a
YouTube client.
I do this using the YouTube API
name and the service name
as well as an Analytics
client.
And this is very important.
We have two clients.
So these are just two
clients in code.
We're going to go ahead.
I'm going to fetch
all my channels.
And I'm going to iterate
through each channel.
And once I iterate through each
channel, I'm going to get
the channel ID.
And now I'm going to use
Analytics, and I'm going to
query for report.
I'm going to query
for the metrics.
This is what's key here--
the annotation clickthrough
rate and an
annotation close rate.
So the clickthrough rate will
tell us what percentage of
people watching this
video are actually
clicking on this thing.
I want to sort it by country.
And I want to sort by annotation
clickthrough rate
descending.
That's what this minus
sign means in
front of this feature.
And if you want to learn more
about the Analytics API, we've
done a bunch of shows about
this, and there's a lot of
documentation, so
check that out.
I'm also doing this for
the month of March.
All right, so I'm going
to execute this.
I'm going to go ahead and
print things out.
I am doing something kind of
tricky here, which is that I'm
looking up the country code
from a tool called the ISO
3166 package.
You can install this using
pip or easy-install, pip,
easy_install ISO 3166.
I'm employing the countries
object--
countries library.
And you can read more about
this online in our
documentation.
Just look for ISO 3166 and
search for it, favorite search
engine, install the package,
you're ready to go.
From that, I'm fetching a
country object from the
country code, fetching a name.
And that's how I get the
pretty name from the
two-letter country code, which
isn't always that useful.
And I'm going to go ahead and
print this out in a table.
So why don't I go ahead
and run this.
Python, InVideo--
let's see--
with Analytics.
Now, I've already approved this,
so I'm going to go ahead
and click Run.
And I'm going to zoom in and
show you guys what we're
looking at here.
What we're looking at now is--
that looks wrong to me.
What we're looking at now is
a country, followed by the
number of views for that month,
followed by the InVideo
Programming clickthrough rate.
And it's not terribly high,
but that's fine.
We can expect that.
And what this allows you to do
is create dashboards as well
as do some kind of testing.
And right now, there aren't a
lot of features, so we'll
definitely do a follow-up show
when there are more features.
But one thing you could do is
you could update it daily to
show the newest video, the
highest-liked video.
You could do any number of
things and automate this
process so that you get the
most number of people
subscribing to your channel.
And that's ultimately the goal
of InVideo Programming is to
get your brand and your channel
in front of potential
viewers that might view your one
video and become long term
returning viewers.
So I'm sorting it by country.
And again, that's
what this does.
And this is just very
standard analytics.
It's using the annotation
clickthrough rate.
And this-- just one warning.
This is also going to include
the old-style annotations,
which we're not currently
planning on providing API for.
Going forward, we're going to
be focusing more on features
to offer InVideo Programming.
So keep a look out on our blog
as well as our release notes
to see when we're uploading
and updating new
features for this.
So that is what I have
for you guys today.
And usually this is about time
when I would ask if there are
any questions.
So I already know what
the question is.
The question is, are
you guys hiring?
And the answer is yes.
So if you want to learn more
about our team and what we do,
go to
developers.google.com/jobs.
And you'll see lots of Google
Developer jobs.
And oh, it's [? Ade ?]
looking very intense, right?
He posed for that.
And these are some of the
different jobs that we have in
Developer Relations or DevRel,
as we like to call it.
So that is all I have
for you guys today.
Come find us on Stack Overflow
at YouTube with the
YouTube-API tag.
We're also at
developers.google.com/youtube
and on Twitter @youtubedev as
well as Google+ at YouTube
Developers.
So thank you guys for joining
me today or whenever you're
watching this show.
And hopefully you'll use the
InVideo Programming and
promote your channel and
be hugely successful.
All right.
Take it easy guys,
and thank you.